[Música]
Hola soy Marina sardiña y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso oriente El magacín
quincenal de France 24 en el que les
acercamos las historias de medio oriente
América Latina Esto es lo que veremos
hoy dos semanas después de los
terremotos más mortales en décadas
Turquía llora la pérdida de decenas de
miles de personas y busca contrarreloj
por un rastro de vida entre los
escombros a la par que Lidia con la
recuperación de una región ahora en
ruinas que acogía a la mayor población
de refugiados sirios del mundo
los sismos también azotaron el noroeste
de Siria en manos de grupo Rebeldes y
opositores una región aislada y
devastada por 12 años de guerra que está
dificultando la entrega de ayuda
humanitarias mientras el régimen sirio
aprovecha la coyuntura para revitalizar
su imagen ante la comunidad
internacional
en Israel la coalición de gobierno
ultraderechista continúa probando
normativas que
aún más los derechos de los ciudadanos
palestinos con una ley que permite la
deportación de presos palestinos
iniciamos en Turquía cuando se cumplen
10 días de los devastadores sismos que
asolaron el sur del país y el noroeste
de Siria dejando a decenas de miles de
personas fallecidas y miles más de
heridos y desaparecidos bajo los
escombros precisamente ankara celebra
elecciones presidenciales este año y
esta catástrofe podría pasarle factura
al presidente allí Perdón muchos acusan
al gobierno de corrupción al permitir la
construcción de viviendas inseguras para
un país con alta actividad sísmica algo
que habría magnificado el desastre los
sismos golpearon con dureza del noroeste
de Siria una región controlada por
distintos grupos Rebeldes y opositores
una tragedia añadida para la población
Siria que sobrevive en medio de una
crisis humanitaria tras 12 años de
Guerra Civil las dinámicas del conflicto
dificultan la entrega de ayuda
humanitarias a través de los pasos
fronterizos y para analizar esto tenemos
a Gabriel garrón la politólogo e
investigador Gracias por estar en France
24 lo primero Cómo se puede atender una
emergencia humanitaria de esta gravedad
en un contexto de un país en guerra con
distintos grupos armados operando y
controlando esta región del norte de
Siria la más golpeada por el terremoto
Sí sí la verdad es que coordinar un
servicio de emergencia internacional
ante una crisis de esta magnitud cuando
estamos delante de un contexto de más de
una década de guerra división
territorial
bloqueos políticos entre diversos entre
varios actores pues obviamente es muy
muy muy complejo Cómo se hace esto en
una digamos en un mundo ideal en una
situación ideal pues obviamente
desplegando y desarrollando unos
mecanismos de cooperación multilateral e
internacionales que existen porque
Naciones Unidas y otros países
obviamente tienen los mecanismos para
desarrollar este tipo de
de actos de emergencia y de ayuda a
terceros países pero que obviamente en
el contexto de Siria esto ha sido
realmente difícil por la por la
situación política y territorial del
país por lo que estos mecanismos
multilaterales no han sido efectivos
bajo ningún concepto especialmente
Durante los tres cuatro primeros días
que es la franja más más importante para
para poder rescatar el mayor número de
personas
precisamente hemos visto una
polarización de estas ayudas en gran
medida por parte del régimen de
basharasad que ahora está dialogando con
países extranjeros qué estrategias está
usando Damasco frente a la comunidad
internacional y si está buscando con
esto revitalizar su imagen después de 12
años de guerra
Claro en relación a incluso a la
pregunta a la pregunta anterior en una
situación ideal a nivel político no
habría ningún tipo de
instrumentalización ningún tipo de
bloqueo internacionalmente los actores
podrían existir este tercer país en
situación de emergencia equipos
internacionales irían a ese país a las
zonas afectadas la capital el gobierno
del país
canalizaría permitiría este tipo de
ayudas e incluso actuaría como casi
reservorio de ayuda internacional todo
esto en el caso sirio especialmente
se ve totalmente afectado por por la
propia matriz de la guerra por la propia
instrumentalización política de de la
guerra Obviamente el gobierno sirio es
uno de los actores
más Implicados En esta
instrumentalización y de hecho se ha
visto como a medida que han ido
avanzando los días a medida que ha
habido mucha más presión internacional y
también obviamente la situación
humanitaria especialmente en el Noroeste
del país ha sido todavía más grave hemos
visto como poco a poco ha ido aceptando
una serie de desarrollos por ejemplo
abrir más pasos fronterizos con Turquía
hasta hace un par de días solo estaba
operativo 1 que además los tres primeros
días de después del terremoto Estaba
totalmente casi
inutilizable por culpa del terremoto y
la destrucción logística en el sur de
Turquía pero también hemos visto como
esta situación del terremoto y
obviamente la enorme catástrofe
humanitaria que vive Siria además encima
de estos 12 años de guerra hemos visto
como también el gobierno sirio está
aprovechando
está digamos de esta plataforma para
volver a establecer relaciones
regionales con países como emiratos como
Jordania Incluso un contingente de ayuda
de Arabia saudí y llegó a Damasco
sean ya digamos
quitado algunas algunas sanciones y
algunas restricciones por parte de
Estados Unidos hoy si no recuerdo mal
Reino Unido también a
ha afirmado que levantará una serie de
por un periodo de tiempo para dar a la
ayuda humanitaria Es decir que esta
situación también está permitiendo al
gobierno desarrollar una serie de
prácticas
en su propio beneficio ya sea político
Ya sea instrumental
precisamente del lado Turco más de mil
muertos eran refugiados sirios personas
que vivían ya en precarias condiciones
del otro lado de la frontera Qué puede
pasar con estos refugiados que han
sobrevivido pero lo han perdido todo
Sí la verdad que una de las de las
situaciones más
más dolorosas Y catastróficas de lo que
de lo que ha sucedido es
el caso los múltiples casos de sirios y
sirias que abandonaron el país por culpa
de la guerra fueron expulsados del país
por culpa de la guerra de la violencia
de las presiones políticas de la
persecución por parte de varios actores
encontraron en Turquía Un refugio A un
refugio más o menos precario de su punto
de vista político porque sabemos la
enorme presión que los refugiados sirios
la mayoría de ellos sufren en Turquía
además en los últimos años con este
ascenso de de un racismo muy muy
evidente y de una política
ultranacionalista muy evidente y que por
desgracia sólo han podido volver a su
país
porque el terremoto acabó con sus vidas
y han sido repatriados a sus ciudades de
origen por lo tanto esto es una
catástrofe de índole humanitaria pero
también política para lo que significa
el pueblo sirio Cómo afecta esto a los
refugiados sirios en Turquía pues
añadiendo una capa más de precariedad es
decir si en Siria Hay un montón de
refugiados en tiendas malviviendo y una
situación muy precaria estas filas pues
se han visto todavía más
más ampliadas con
Los afectados por el terremoto y en el
caso de Turquía
lo mismo desde su punto de vista de
desarrollo económico acceso a fondos ya
sea humanitarios ya sea de otra índole
económica pues obviamente el segmento de
sirios refugiados en Turquía están en el
escalafón más bajo de de la sociedad
obviamente más frágiles con mayor
precariedad y con una situación mucho
más complicada no pueden volver a su
casa seguramente su casa está destruida
y ya sea por la guerra ya sea por el
terremoto marzo se cumplen 12 años de
guerra en Siria Qué siente la población
en estos momentos donde además de esta
catástrofe el conflicto continúa
sí la sensación general obviamente es de
una de hastío de hastío muy muy profundo
en muchos casos
gran parte de los sirios lo que lo que
quieren es intentar llevar una situación
de vida normal Más allá de las
aspiraciones políticas que se pueden
tener socioeconómicamente el país está
en un momento absolutamente terrorífico
en áreas que el gobierno
recuperó a lo largo de estos años la
situación de normalidad es
un Espejismo en muchos casos porque
socioeconómicamente son son zonas
también castigadas en aquellas partes
donde todavía
hay grupos Rebeldes o incluso en la
administración del Norte y el este de
Siria bajo bajo milicias kurdas Estos
son áreas que llamamos áreas de
indeterminación internacional es decir
que el desarrollo del conflicto sirio en
los próximos años dependerá muchísimo de
lo que Turquía Rusia el gobierno de
Siria y otros actores internacionales
sean capaces o quieran incluso hacer con
estas zonas que todavía no están bajo
bajo control del gobierno por lo tanto
es una guerra todavía en activo es una
guerra que ha causado una destrucción
material enorme una cantidad de muertos
y ve desplazados enorme que todavía
tiene unas causas políticas sin resolver
Y que por lo tanto el terremoto añade
como decía una capa más de sufrimiento y
es esta sensación de un ciclo permanente
de violencia es decir la violencia
política la violencia material la
destrucción de las ciudades
la cantidad de desplazados y por lo
tanto el dolor que significa estar fuera
de un país sino poder volver a ello Pues
el terremoto añade una una capa más en
ese en ese sentido
gracias Gabriel por este análisis y
terminamos en Israel por amplia mayoría
el parlamento israelí aprobó una ley
para revocar la ciudadanía o residencia
de palestinos condenados por terrorismo
una medida que estaba en la agenda del
gobierno ultraderechista pero que se
aceleró tras los recientes ataques en
Jerusalén este ocupado Esta es la última
de una serie de normativas contra los
palestinos nos lo explica nuestra
corresponsal en Jerusalén Yanira Gómez
Muñoz
esta ley que anula la ciudadanía o
residencia de atacantes palestinos pone
un marco legal a una medida que ya se
había aplicado por ejemplo en diciembre
Israel retiró la residencia y expulsó de
su Jerusalén natal al abogado palestino
francés salaham murie acusado de planear
atentados pero ahora la ley concreta
esta revocación que conlleva en la
deportación a gaza Oasis Jordania una
vez El condenado cumpla con prisión y se
verifique que recibe dinero de la
autoridad nacional Palestina grupos de
Derechos Humanos denuncian que la ley es
discriminatoria porque solo aplica a
palestinos presos por terrorismo Y estos
a su vez se enfrentan a otra nueva
medida duchas de 4 minutos en una franja
de una hora al día Pues el ministro de
seguridad itamar benjivir quiere reducir
lo que considera que son comodidades en
paralelo a esto se ha aprobado también
una operación a gran escala en Jerusalén
este Isis Jordania que aunque no se
saben los detalles ya es visible en una
mayor en un mayor despliegue y militar y
Asimismo el gobierno israelí ha decidido
regularizar en cisjordania Nueva
asentamientos ilegales y construir Diez
mil viviendas en colonias ya existentes
medidas que al final sólo incrementan el
riesgo de una mayor escalada
llegamos así al final de esta edición de
Expreso de oriente Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y los invito a enviar sus
comentarios a las redes sociales que
aparecen en sus pantallas y a seguir
toda nuestra información en nuestra
página web France 24.com
[Música]